let's try and be a word detective
today welcome to language shapes
perception and unlock word meanings
through context
clues have you ever come across a word
you didn't know while reading and try to
guess its meaning how did you figure it
out if not then today we will define
context clues provide different examples
of the types of context clues and
practice how to identify context clues
in a
text but what is a context clue context
clues are pieces of information from the
text that help us figure out the meaning
of unfamiliar words imagine you're a
detective Gathering Clues from the
sentences around the unknown word to
make an educated guess about its
definition there are different types of
context clues but today we will only
mention three of them definition context
clues synonym context clues and antonym
context
clues this type of clue is when the
meaning of the word is directly stated
in the text the sentences actually
contain the definition of climate change
for example climate change which refers
to long-term shifts in temperature in
weather patterns results in changes to
eco system and the
environment and as you can see here this
is the definition long-term shifts in
temperature and weather patterns so the
definition of that word is inside the
sentence another context clue is synonym
contact clues in this type of context
clues there's another word in the text
that has a similar meaning to the
unknown word the synonym for the term
Extinction
is in this sentence can you try and
figure it out what's the clue where is
the clue
here another word in the text has a
similar meaning to the unknown word in
this example eradication has a similar
meaning to Extinction for example the
effect of climate change could lead to
the extinction or complete eradication
of certain species on this
planet antonym is another type of
context clues this contact clue is when
there is another word in the text that
means the opposite as the unfamiliar
word the antonym of drought is somewhere
in this
sentence can you try and find the
antonym context clue
here whereas some regions are
experiencing prolonged droughts there
are other areas across the globe that
are enduring devastating
floods while a flood means an
overflowing of water a drought is a
period of very dry
weather the term drought would be the
opposite of floods that's why these are
called
antonyms now let's try and uncover some
contact
clues read the following sentences
carefully each sentence can contains an
unfamiliar word let's think about the
meaning of the unfamiliar words and
identify them using context clues the
ones that we just
learned as the hurricane approached the
ocean surface was filled with turbulence
an unsteady violent movement making it
dangerous for ships to
navigate now the question is what is the
meaning of the underlined word what type
of contact clue is used here the
underlined word is turbulence let's try
and answer that
together I'm pretty sure you all guessed
it by
now the word turbulence means an
unsteady violent
movement and the type of clue here is
definition context
clue here we have another examp example
after 10 hours of heavy rainfall the
Wind and Rain of the storm did not Abate
rather they began to
intensify what is the meaning of the
underlined word what type of contact
clue is used here let's take a few
seconds to
guess here the word aade is supposed to
be an unknown or unfamiliar word it
means to decrease or slow down
antonym context
clue here we have another example exper
described the hurricane as destabilizing
or disruptive as it caused widespread
destruction in coastal areas what is the
meaning of the underlined word
destabilizing and what type of contact
glue is used
here and the the answer is synonym
context glue is used here and the
synonym of
destabilizing is is
disruptive here's a short summary of
what we just
discussed context glues are tools for
understanding and deciphering unknown
words while reading whether that's a
normal regular reading or if it's an
academic Passage another thing worth
mentioning is that there are different
types of contact CLS definition contact
CLA synonym context clu and antonym
context
clues and this is it for today if you
have similar examples you can comment
down below and give us your thoughts you
can also add your references to those
examples down below thank you for
watching this video
make sure to comment like And subscribe
if you like our content till next time
take
care